So, I think as a woman
in the workplace,
as a young woman,
I had to almost like pretend
to not be a woman
and not be feminine
and just ignore that identity.
And so, all of a sudden,
I was like at a concert
and I just like had somatic experiences.
I was like, oh, I'm feeling
the music in my body.
I was like, there's information here,
there's a gut feeling.
Carine Carmy,
welcome to 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you today?
Amazing.
Thank you so much for having me.
It's a pleasure.
No, no, the honor is mine
and the pleasure is mine,
because I'm always excited
to dive into a whole new industry
and a whole new market
that I know absolutely nothing about
but I want to know more about.
Before we dive into
what you're doing with Origin,
I'd love to go back a little bit
through UPenn researcher,
and you're getting
your bachelor's degree there.
And you go on to do all sorts
of interesting stuff,
whether it's with 3D printing
or being a VP at Shapeways,
instructor at General Assembly,
VP Sales at Amino,
all sorts of different weird things.
Take me a little bit through
your journey up until origin.
Yeah. I'm happy too.
And you know, I think
the common thread is just like
follow your curiosity, right,
because you never know where
the world is going to take you.
I grew up in LA
and I went to school
on the East Coast at Penn undergrad.
And it was a really actually,
amazing experience.
I loved it there.
And I thought I was going
to be a journalist.
And then after a lot of pressure
from family and also
you know, kind of seeing
the business side,
I was like, okay,
this is actually very compelling.
So, started the econ
and I graduated actually
into the 2008 recession.
So, that was something special.
And I definitely feel for everyone
who's graduating this year.
And with covid,
I know it's crazy, crazy times.
But I was lucky enough
to be able to get a job
in management consulting.
And this was 2008.
Like the week before I joined
they let us know that
they had let go 20% of the firm.
So, I'm kind of like holding on
to my chair, like,
what is this world going to be.
And it was just an amazing boot camp.
You know, I think there's various ways
you can start your career.
I just feel really grateful
to be in a position
where my job literally, everyday,
was learn as much as I can
as quickly as possible
and provide the best advice
we can using data and analytics.
And it was a good boot camp.
But about a few years in,
I started really developing my passion
for technology and digital media.
And I actually remember
I saw this one video
that came out of the MIT Media Lab
and it was called The Sixth Sense,
and it was the early days of AR/VR.
And I was like,
this is the coolest thing
I've ever seen.
I have to work in tech.
And I don't have any skills
but I got to work in this industry.
And we had a digital media
kind of consulting arm of monitor
called Marketspace,
and they were actually spinning out
the practice into its all
like kinds of digital consulting studio.
And so, I kind of just knocked
on their doors.
It was three partners.
I was like, you've got
to take me with you. I'm coming.
So, we started
a boutique digital media firm
called MarketspaceNext for few years.
And it was amazing.
So, I went from like 50,000 feet
to 10,000 feet and we did everything
from go to market strategies
and UX design,
and you just kind of
make it up as we go along.
But it was a great learning experience.
And both of my parents
are small business owners.
So, I always thought about
kind of doing the startup thing.
And New York at the time,
like the New York tech scene,
was maybe 10,000 people,
it was really small in 2009.
The tech meet up was like
the literal event
that everyone would go to.
And so, I just started applying to jobs.
And it took me about a year and a half
to actually get someone to believe in me,
that this person who
had no real operational skills.
I basically, this is like the pro tip,
I wrote a blog post about 3D printing
because I thought it was
a really interesting category.
And then I sent it to the CEO
of the company Shapeways,
which is hiring
for a head of marketing.
And I was like, you know
I know it doesn't look like it on paper,
but like, just take me.
I promise you,
it's not going to be a bad thing.
And it was really
one of the best career moves
I was able to make.
We were really small at the time.
This is when 3D printing
was just taking off.
And I got to join
the team really early days
and help hope like,
just build this category.
And it was so fun
because 3D printing is much bigger now.
But at the time
it was all of these like,
really passionate designers
all around the world
making products in ways that
they've never been able to do before.
So, it felt like we were really
democratizing, manufacturing
and creation.
And I learned a lot.
I made a lot of mistakes.
I definitely had my first office cry
where I was like,
I don't know how to do it,
you know, what does this mean.
Like, I can't learn all
of this like today.
But it was an amazing experience.
And I got to go from first marketer,
to leading our marketing team,
and that over time building out
our marketing community,
e-commerce teams.
And you know, I felt really lucky
to have people believe in me, too,
because there's hard work.
But you also have to have
the right leadership
to kind of seize them.
So, that was a good boot camp,
made a lot of mistakes,
but it was really fun.
And then, I was thinking
about moving to California,
kind of the pull from home kept pulling.
And I had always been interested
in health care.
And we had done a lot
of health care work
at Monitor and at Marketspace.
And this was when digital health
has kind of started to grow as a category
and we start to see more innovative
direct to consumer
and just innovative models
on how we improve
the health care system.
And I decided to stop being skeptical
and believe that
you could change healthcare.
And so, I joined an amazing founder,
David Vivero, at a company called Amino,
which is now one of the leading providers
of kind of navigating
the health care system
and financial wellness
around health care.
Because like today, it's still
I mean, you know, this, you know,
with health care in the US,
it's crazy.
Most people can't even afford
a $500 surprise medical bill.
And the difference between walking
to like urgent care in ER
is just insane.
And there's no price transparency.
There's no quality transparency.
So, we're really trying to tackle that.
And go ahead.
We're you going to say something?
I keep going back to this experience.
It was my first week at Stanford.
One of the economics professors
that I had, was talking about
the fact that most Americans can't pay
a $400 bill if their car breaks down
in the middle of the street.
Which to me, it was unbelievable.
It was unfathomable to imagine
that the majority of the of US families
can't afford a $400 emergency.
And what does that mean about
a broken financial system where,
you know, there's
a consumer spending on one hand,
but lack of information and understanding
about rational decision making.
But sorry, that's my digression.
Go ahead.
No.
Look, I'm with you.
And we can have
a whole conversation around equity
in this country.
And I think that's been,
for me, one of the biggest,
kind of pull points,
because at Amino
and even with Shapeways, it's like,
you shouldn't have
this asymmetric either power information
or even financial tools.
And even the same is true
in women's health.
But that reality of just
how deeply uneducated most Americans,
myself included, are about
how health care works,
like what is the deductible.
It's we're kind of hiding
or the system hides behind
these complicated words and systems.
But it truly has
a major impact on the livelihood
of individuals
and that impacts their work.
And you see it now in covid,
so,] many people are afraid
of losing their jobs,
not just because of losing their jobs,
but losing health care.
And so, this whole system
fundamentally needs to change.
But politics aside,
we were able to grow
the team in the business a lot.
And ultimately we pivoted
from a direct consumer company to B2B.
And that's when I helped build out
our sales team
and kind of customer success.
And as you could probably tell
throughout my career, I was like,
I want to do more.
I want to learn more.
And like, I really love
seeing all aspects of the business.
Like I love marketing.
But for me that was just the entry point.
And so, I'll never forget
a few years into Amino,
the founder, David, took me to lunch.
And he's like, "Carine, have you ever
thought about being a CEO?"
And I was like, "Honestly, no."
Like I'd never put that on my radar.
And just like that conversation
opened up this possibility for me.
And so, I'm eternally grateful to David.
He's honestly the best person
I've worked with in my career.
And it was that moment where
as we started moving into B2B,
I am not the best
enterprise sales leader
in the country, like the team
and the company needed someone else.
I was living between two cities
and just we all decided it was best
if I transitioned out.
So, I took some time off.
Which was the most terrifying thing
I'd ever done.
But I highly recommend it
to anyone in their kind of like
early mid career,
if you don't know.
It's really helpful to get that clarity.
And I started working with a coach
and just did like a lot
of that personal exploration
that I had never stopped to do.
Graduating at 21.
I was like, go, go, go.
And I was like, wait, who am I.
What do I want to actually
do with my life.
And I think on a personal note,
I felt this like,
Go ahead.
I really want to pause at that break
and defining the time, because
I'm both feeling in myself
that this rush
and this need to embrace
every opportunity possible.
Especially given that if we come
with a place where we do have a privilege
to have those opportunities,
it's very hard for me to sleep
an extra hour if I know that
I could be meeting somebody like you
and have a show like this.
But talk to me a little bit about
this decision to take some time off,
work with the coach,
understand a little bit about yourself.
How old were you?
And what was actually going
on during that time?
Yeah. So, it was 2018.
I'm 34 now.
So, a couple of years ago,
I was like 32 or 31 at the time.
32. Yeah.
I can't do math.
Whatever.
Anyways, early 30's.
And it was terrifying, honestly.
So, I got married.
My husband was in LA,
I was living in San Francisco.
I flew back after the wedding
and I had a breakdown
in shavasana and yoga.
And I was like,
"What the hell am I doing?
What is my life right now?"
You know, and I'm like crying
although, like on the yoga mat,
and the woman's like, "Are you okay?"
I'm like, "I'm fine."
"Can I just go right now?"
And I loved the team at Amino so much.
And I like you orient
your life around companies
when you're in the startup world.
And I think that's amazing.
And I don't regret it.
But I also, I wasn't at that point
the right fit for that role anymore.
And I was like,
"Okay. So, now what?"
And so, I had this moment where I said,
I can either go jump into a new job
and like the moneymaking person in me
is like, okay, let's go do that.
But I know that if I had gotten
to that point where I was so misaligned
with myself and my goals,
like whatever I was going to do next,
I was just going to be in the same place
a few years later.
And so, I actually,
I called it like, I needed
a spiritual chiropractor.
I think I just need to just get back
into alignment and figure out who am I
and what do I value
and how do I get my life
to reflect that and not just get
stuck on this pull.
Because I think, especially
in Silicon Valley or these big cities
where there's a lot
of very prominent models of success,
you could just think that
that's what it's supposed
to look like for you.
And I think for a lot of people,
it's great.
But let's write our own train.
You know, we don't need to get pulled
by the examples that
have been pulled before us.
So, I spent a lot of money on a coach.
It was like terrifying.
It was like I'm unemployed
and I'm like spending thousands
of dollars on working
with this person.
Best decision I made in my life.
Like I actually met with her
a couple of weeks ago
around my birthday.
And I was like, can you imagine
like, we were sitting there
with a whiteboard and I was like,
I have no idea.
And now, I'm managing
a 28 person team
like venture funded this whole thing.
I'm like, this is crazy.
And in a space
that's so important to me
but was like not even present
at the time.
So, it took a lot of work.
And I think for me
it was obviously very much around
like what do I value
and how do I think about
my criteria for what's next.
But it was also about,
actually like the mental health
side of things.
I think what was ultimately happening
was I associated productivity
and doing with success.
And obviously you need to do
to be successful.
But that's not the end state.
And I had to unlearn that in a big way.
So, lots of personal growth.
And I think on also
a really personal note,
I don't know if this
is particularly true to women,
but it's been a theme on
a lot of conversations I've had
is I was really disassociated
from my body.
I had worked so hard.
Also, I think as a woman
in the workplace,
as a young woman,
I had to almost like pretend
to not be a woman
and not be feminine
and just ignore that identity.
And so, all of a sudden,
I was like at a concert
and I just like had somatic experiences.
I was like, oh, I'm feeling
the music in my body.
I was like, there's information here.
There's a gut feeling.
And I really reconnected
with intuition and gut feeling
and what that meant
from a physical component,
which then kind of,
it was both very personal,
but then got me
so much more connected
to what I'm doing today
and realizing how many women,
because of external pressures,
have been taught
to normalize pain
or to normalize discomfort.
And so, I was back in LA
and I connected with a friend of mine
from high school
who had just had a baby.
And she was telling me everything
she was going on in her body.
And this happens to everyone.
But like her abs were separated,
her neck and shoulder were killing her.
She was leaking,
she can't control her bladder.
She's having painful sex.
And this is a woman of privilege
who has some
of the best insurance in the country.
And that was her reality.
And so, we started talking.
She's a friend from high school,
now, my co-founder.
And she basically
googled around desperation
and found a physical therapist
and was dramatically healed.
And we started just talking
and we're like, wait,
this is a standard of care in France.
Like you get PT
when you break your pinky
but not when you deliver
a child through your vagina
or through an invasive C-section.
Like ,what's wrong here
and why hasn't this taken off.
And that really kicked off now
the journey that is Origin.
Huh. So, you're discovering
this whole opportunity through
sort of a self discovery experience.
And it starts with connecting
the mind and body,
but it's discovering that
there is this whole,
I don't know if it's a taboo subject
or if it's just, you know,
it's an industry.
How do you identify that
the people aren't working on this?
Because you mentioned,
now that you mention it,
it seems so ridiculous
that people are getting
physical therapy when anything,
at the slightest discomfort,
but something like childbirth,
which obviously, as a man,
I'll never understand the pain,
but going something
as traumatic to the body as it is,
you don't really get that treatment.
How do you explain that people
aren't trying to solve it
other than perhaps Origin?
You know, I think there's a few things.
So one, there's obviously
a lot of gender bias in medicine.
It's systemic in this country.
So, like until the 90s,
we were using men's bodies to study
issues that only impacted women
or primarily impacted women.
So, you can actually do research
on ovarian cancer in men.
Right?
So, like this is 90s, like 1990s.
So, we have just
this deep systemic gender bias
in medicine that's well documented.
And it extends everything.
It's women are less likely
to have their pain taken seriously.
They're more likely
to have heart attacks being misdiagnosed.
Just end to end, women have had
to become bigger advocates
for their own care.
So, that's just messed up.
But that's the fundamental reality.
I think we also have
what was historically probably stigma
or taboo subjects around
pelvic health or vaginas.
Or like we would just associate
anything pelvic oriented around.
either fertility or sex,
which are things
that are not often talked about
in public discourse,
although that's changing.
And then I think
there's just structural reasons
that hasn't happened before.
So, we're one of the only,
and I can tell you a little bit
of what we do, but,
Please.
Most of the people who do
what we do don't take insurance.
And so, you think
about mainstream access
really has to be affordable
for this to take off.
And at our core,
just to kind of level set.
So, Origin is providing physical therapy
for women and mothers.
And we are treating
these incredibly common
but often overlooked issues
that impact women, often around
pregnancy and postpartum,
but like throughout our lives.
So, whether that's painful sex
or you're an athlete
and you're doing crossfit
and you can't control your bladder,
all the way through menopause
and you're having, you know,
your muscles are weakening
and you need more support.
And PT is actually
the first line treatment
for all of these issues
that women experience.
But, as we said,
there's some supply side issues,
there's some payor problems
and just the cultural norms.
And I think
what was really interesting for us
is as we started digging
into this early days,
the investors weren't there yet to.
So, investors used to say,
fertility is women's health.
And then we'd be like, okay,
but what about everything after fertility.
Like, you know,
you have 50% of the population
experiencing these issues.
And because all of the best companies
at the time were in the fertility space,
that's what the market associated
with women's health.
And that was, you know,
even just two years ago.
Today, I just I can't even tell you,
it's like an explosion of creativity
in women's health right now.
Everything from CPG
and menopause and pregnancy,
it's very different.
But a few years ago,
that wasn't the case.
And it's probably because
there weren't as many women VCs
frankly, who were,
we were pitching to mainly men.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
So, talk to me a little bit more
about how this boom
that you're experiencing.
Because until now it sounded like,
you know, you almost stumbled upon
this new marketing opportunity
that's obviously making
a huge impact on women's lives.
And really, really an important space.
But you're also talking about the fact
that there is an explosion,
not just that you're working on,
but there's a lot of creativity
in the space
and you're attributing a lot of it
to female in VC positions
where they're also interested
in seeing these types of products.
But is that
the main reason you think?
I don't know if it's the main reason.
But I think it's just like
a perfect storm
that was kind of putting
the blinders on.
And then you also just have
to think about
this cultural cycle that we were in.
So, let's say you gave birth.
And then your body is a wreck.
And then you go
to your doctor six weeks later
as the only touchpoint you have
and then you don't see
your doctor for another year after that.
No one is helping you feel better.
And so, that normalizes pain.
Right?
And so, every woman
who's been through that cycle before
is just taught that
that's just the way it is.
There's no real solution.
Like, I'm going to have to pee my pants
for the rest of my life,
or sex is always going to hurt.
This is bullshit. Right?
So, but like, if that's the psychology,
then it's really hard to see and say, oh,
like, there's actually a real solution
without either saying
something was wrong with me
for not finding it
or like what's wrong
with the medical system.
I think people are waking up
to that in a big way.
So, I don't think it's
just VCs, you have Me Too.
You have like so many trends
that have shifted the conversation.
And I think even culturally now,
people are just far more open
on Instagram about
these issues themselves.
So, you're just saying a lot of people
it's almost like an awakening, like,
no, I'm not going to live
with this anymore.
And we have so many patients
who are coming in
and it's just really intergenerational.
Like, someone is coming in,
maybe postpartum
and they're bringing
their younger sister,
this is truly happening,
they're bringing their younger sister
who's an athlete, and their mom
who's going through menopause.
It's like, no, none of us
are going to go through
this shit anymore.
Because like, why would we.
I love that. I love that.
It's a revolution.
Yeah.
It really sounds like that.
What are some tips that you can think of
in retrospect about identifying
interesting market opportunities
in, you know, these hidden markets
that perhaps that today
we are not comfortable talking about
or they're just underserved in general?
Yeah.
You know, I wish there was like,
here's the formula
for finding new markets.
I think it does require, obviously,
just having some
of your own intuition expertise.
But I think, you know,
part of it is
I always think about this framework.
There's a lot of people
talk about product market fit,
but I think a lot about
product market capital fit.
So, you have to have both like,
the product that's serving
the right people,
but then also a way to fund that.
And you see a lot of companies
who are like, let's say,
trying to go get VC capital
that are not necessarily
going to scale in that way.
Or, you know,
just the conversation around
how those three have come together,
I think have been missing the mark.
But I would just say
there's some early signals on
how industries are changing.
So, let's say,
just looking at health care.
Health care 1.0 around digital health
was like, let's do
what was happening in person
and make it like better and digital.
And that was on medical
and all these other companies
who just like brought it up
to the consumer age.
And now it's like,
what is the real product,
digital first solution that's going
to actually be a game changer
for the patient.
And so, I think
you'll probably see similar cycles
in other industries where,
first is just about like,
let's just make it better.
And now it's actually let's make
it new and far more effective
than we could have ever imagined.
I love that.
Carine, thank you so much
for taking the time to do this.
This was inspiring and so interesting.
And it sounds like what you're doing
is really a hugely impactful
and has a positive impact
on so many women.
And I can't wait to see
where Origin Physical Therapy grows
and takes you.
Before we end this,
I want to ask you
the most difficult question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
It's always the hard one.
You gave me a little hint
that this is going to happen.
So, I had a minute to think about it.
But I think the three words
would be creative, curious
and unstoppable.
I love that. Yes.
Okay. Finally, I think this was,
this is the first episode
in about 200 episodes
where somebody said unstoppable.
And I love that word.
I love it.
Yeah. We're just going to go.
I'm so grateful.
Thank you so, so much.
Stay safe. Stay healthy.
And I can't wait
to share this with the world.
Thank you.